Donald Trump did end up having a press briefing
yesterday after not having them over the weekend
after the bleach injection fiasco led to him
just walking out without taking questions
from the Friday press briefing.
And it was a really weird one yesterday.
First that was scheduled as normal for 5 p.m.
as a White House Corona Virus Task Force press
briefing.
Then it was canceled.
Then very haphazardly, a Rose Garden press
conference was scheduled to replace the press
briefing.
And to Trump's credit, he didn't take questions.
But for whatever reason, there was one question
that was even remotely connected to the bleach
injection fiasco.
I've been asking around whether reporters
were warned off of asking questions about
the bleach fiasco or what.
But in any case, the one question that was
asked was about the number of disinfectant
ingestion related phone calls to poison control
centers across the country, which have increased.
Does Trump take any responsibility, was the
question.
Big shocker.
He does not take any responsibility.
Take a look at the video.
Larry Hogan specifically said they've seen
a spike in people using disinfectant after
your comments last week.
I know you said they were saké.
I can't imagine why.
Yeah.
Take any responsibility.
Oh, no, I can't imagine.
I can't imagine that.
Yeah, go ahead, please.
President, he can't imagine why.
Well, because he wondered aloud, what if we
hit the body with an injected disinfectant
just four days ago?
That's why the question is being posed to
him.
And we're now learning of many more instances
of this.
The reporter there mentioned, Marilyn, the
increase in Maryland of calls to poison control
related to the ingestion of household cleaners.
We also have some news out of Kansas.
In Kansas, a state health officer, Lee Norman,
said poison control saw a 40 percent increase
in cleaning chemical related cases in the
last few days, including one guy who drank
a product because someone suggested it.
We don't know whether that someone was Donald
Trump, someone who heard it from Donald Trump
or just a mere coincidence and not related
to Donald Trump at all.
So here's what I want to ask you about.
I've been reading the new defense online from
mostly people on the right, but even from
some people on the left kind of agreeing here.
And they've been saying, if you are so dumb
that you drink bleach because the president
mentions it as a possible corona virus treatment,
you don't deserve to survive.
In other words, it's a sort of Darwinian thinning,
thinning of the herd type of thing, even though
it's obviously not really Darwinian, but it's
colloquially named that if you were this dumb,
that simply because Trump talks about drinking
bleach, you do it, that it is a calling of
the week, thinning of the herd sort of thing,
and that we shouldn't really worry about it.
And it reminds me of this idea that if you
want to thin the herd, you get rid of the
warning labels and just let it happen.
So what
do you think?
I mean, my my reaction tends to be I don't
condemn the cond I condemn the con men.
So it feels weird to me.
Just write it, writing it off that way.
It's not you know, that it's not the job of
the president.
It's not excusable that a president says things
that goad dumb people, if that's what you
believe they are into killing themselves.
There's a very sort of utilitarian reaction,
which is that a lot of the people aren't dying.
They're just getting sick enough from drinking
bleach that they need to go into the hospital.
They require medical services.
They consume medical resources.
And it's taking hospital space away from people
who actually just have coronavirus.
That would be a very utilitarian reaction.
But a lot of people tweeting me and this seems
to be the predominant reaction, the contempt
must be for the con men, not for the cond.
Ignoring the plight of those who are cond
is not particularly progressive.
And I agree with that.
I want to hear from you.
Bigger picture, regardless of the cond we
can objectively say a president shouldn't
be floating such ideas, period, regardless
of the impact that they have.
One other reaction has been, if you only harm
yourself, then we should be less concerned.
It's not even clear to me that people who
fall for this stuff are only harming themselves.
They may be suggesting other people do it.
They may be harming themselves in a way that
then can leave their children without a parent.
The idea of only harming yourself is one that
we would have to grapple with a little more
more distinctly.
Overall, though, people hope to be able to
trust the office of the presidency.
Until now, many people have been told you
can trust the office of the presidency.
So maybe the problem isn't with.
The people, but with a system that has allowed
trust in the office of the presidency to be
so exploited by a con man like Donald Trump,
blaming the frightened masses, so to speak,
as one person said to me on Twitter, rather
than those with the institutional power doesn't
strike me as progressive.
And I agree with that.
But I want to hear from you